[موسيقى]
لذا
سنقدم لاحقًا اليوم حزمة من
العقوبات الجماعية والموجهة
للقادة الأوروبيين للحصول على موافقتهم ، حيث
يتم التنسيق بشكل وثيق مع
شركائنا وحلفائنا ،
الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة وكندا والنرويج ولكن
أيضًا على سبيل المثال
ستشمل هذه الحزمة في اليابان وأستراليا
عقوبات مالية تحد بشدة
من وصول روسيا إلى
أسواق رأس المال ،
وسيكون لهذه العقوبات تأثير كبير
على الاقتصاد الروسي ، وقد واجه بالفعل
ضغوطًا شديدة في الأسابيع الأخيرة
، وستتراكم هذه الضغوط الآن وستؤدي
هذه العقوبات إلى قمع زيادة النمو الاقتصادي لروسيا.
ترفع تكاليف الاقتراض
التضخم وتكثف تدفق رأس المال
وتدهور أساسه الصناعي تدريجيًا
[موسيقى]
لذلك
أنت